I should think well I feel fear about
this and therefore I shouldn't do it
it's normal to be to feel fear like
you'd have to definitely something
mentally wrong you should feel fear and
there's a friend of mine here who says
like starting company is like staring at
the abyss and eating glass and the some
truth to that and the successful company
is very much more about how quick are
you to fix the mistakes not will you
make mistakes the one thing I couldn't
compress with the cost launched there's
only a few options and the us options
are way too expensive and I ended up
going to Russia three times to try to
buy the biggest ICBM and the Russian
nuclear fleet he's the CEO of SpaceX and
Tesla Motors and the chairman of Solar
City his goals of starting these
businesses always revolve around
changing the world and humanity he has
an estimated net worth of 11.5 billion
dollars he's Elon Musk and here is my
take on his top 10 rules of success part
2 rule number one is my personal
favorite and make sure to stick around
all the way to the ends of some special
bonus clips also as Elon stalkin if you
said something that really resonates
with you please leave it in the comments
below put quotes around it so other
people can be inspired as well enjoy
[Music]
you are unusually fearless and willing
to go in the face of other people
telling you something that's crazy and I
know a lot of pretty great new people
you still stand out where does that come
from or how do you think about making a
decision when everyone tells me this is
a crazy idea where do you get the
internal strength to do that well since
all I'd say I actually think I see if
feels they are quite strongly so it's
not as though I just have the absence of
fear I've I feel it quite strongly but
there are times when something is
important enough you believe in it
enough that you do it in spite of fear
so speaking of important things like
people shouldn't think III should if you
think well I feel fear about this and
therefore I shouldn't do it it's normal
to be to feel fear like you'd have to
definitely something mentally wrong you
shouldn't feel fear so you just feel it
and let the importance of it drive you
to do it anyway yeah you know actually
we're something that can be helpful as
fatalism some degree you could just
think it's just accept the probabilities
then that diminishes fear so Miss
Notting SpaceX I thought the odds of
success were less than 10% and I just
accepted that actually probably I would
just lose lose everything but that maybe
would make some progress if we could
just move the ball forward even if we
died maybe some other company could pick
up the baton and move and keep moving it
forward so that we still do some good
yeah say what Tesla iBook Gilad to the
clock company succeeding were extremely
low I would definitely advise people
residing company to expect a long turd
of quite high difficulty yeah but it
means long as people take super focused
on creating absolute best product or
service that really delights their end
customer if they stay focused on that
then
and it should be basic if you get it
such that your customers want you to
succeed then you probably will all right
get the focus on the customer delivering
for them yeah
make sure if your customers love you you
will your odds of success are
dramatically higher when does have to be
focused on the short term and money
coming in when creating a company
because otherwise the company will die
so that the I think that a lot of times
people think like creating company is
going to be fun I would say it's not
it's really not that fun I mean their
periods of fun and their periods of
which were [ __ ] awful and particularly
if you CEO of the company you actually
have a distillation of all the worst
problems in a company so there's no
point in spending your time on things
that are going right so you only spend
on things on your time on things that
are going wrong and there's things that
are going wrong that other people can't
can't take care of so you're like the
worst you have a filter for the crappers
problems in the company most pernicious
and painful problems so I wouldn't say
it's I think you have to feel quite
compelled to do it and have a fairly
high pain threshold and there's a friend
of mine who says like starting companies
like sharing the abyss and eating glass
and did some truth to that we're showing
a clear this part is that you're going
to be constantly facing the
extermination of the company because
most most startups fail that's like 90%
ugly 99% of of starts fail so I bet that
so staring into give this part you can't
see constantly saying okay if I don't
get this right the company will die
should be quite direct question as well
and and then the eating glass part is
you've got you've got to do you've got
to be the problem you gonna so you're
going to work on the problem that the
company needs you to work on that
promise you want to work on and so that
but that's the you end up working on
problems that that you'd really wish you
weren't working
and so that's the eating glass part then
that goes on for a long time so how do
you keep your focus on the big picture
when you're constantly faced with we
could be out of business in a month well
it's just a very small percentage of
mental energies on the on the big
picture like you know you know where you
generally heading for and and the actual
path is going to be some sort of
zigzagging thing in that direction and
try not to deviate to frost on the path
that that you want to be on but you're
going to have to do that some degree but
I don't want to I don't want to diminish
the I mean I think the product the
profit motive is it is a is a good one
if the rules of an industry are properly
set up so there's only fundamentally
wrong with profit in fact profit just
means that people are paying you more
for whatever you're doing then you're
spending to create it that's a good
thing and if you're not if that's not
the case then you'll be out of business
and rightfully so sure you're not adding
enough value I was like I really need
some thoughts like how can I provide
advice that would be most helpful and
I'm not sure I've given enough thought
to to that to give you the best possible
answer but I think I think certainly
being focused on something that you're
confident will have high value to
someone else and just being really
rigorous in making that assessment
because people are tend to natural human
tendencies wishful thinking so a
challenge for entrepreneurs is to say
well what's the difference between
really believing in new ideals and
sticking sticking to them versus
pursuing some unrealistic dream that
doesn't actually have merit and it that
is it that is a really difficult thing
to to tell you can you tell the
difference between those two things so
you need to be sort of very rigorous in
your self self analysis having certainly
extremely tenacious and
and then just work like hell I mean you
just have to put in you know 80 hour 80
100 hour weeks every week and then I
like that's all those things improve the
other success okay
I mean if other people are putting in
40-hour work weeks and you're putting in
100 hour work weeks then even if you're
doing the same thing you know that in
one year you will achieve what they
achieve you will achieve in four months
what it takes them a year to achieve so
failures are not the most terrible
things well you have to learn from it
and react to it yeah exactly is when
you're building something new
destroy mistakes and it's important to
to recognize those mistakes acknowledge
them and take corrective action and the
successful company is very much more
about how quick are you to fix the
mistakes not will you make mistakes or I
made a mistake
yeah absolutely yeah and if you see the
difference between a startup that is
successful one that is not is because
the successful one they both made
mistakes but the successful one
recognized mistakes fix them very
quickly and the unsuccessful one tries
to deny that the mistakes exist you know
extremely smart people are sometimes
quite arrogant because they believe in
what they believe in right and so when
they face criticism it's less likely to
admit you know they can make mistakes
was that in your case I learnt it when I
was doing when I studying physics the
the you know in physics you've taught to
always question yourself your thoughts
always assume that you're wrong not
assume that you're right and you have to
prove yourself not not wrong and I think
that that that physics framework is
really where where I learnt it and it's
very effective for wonderful learning
counterintuitive things that aren't
obvious hmm so you are very famous in
saying that failure is actually an
option and if you're not failing which
that means you're not innovative yeah
there's not like I like failure and
you're like failure is terrible but if
you only do things that are certain to
succeed then you're only going to be
doing very obvious thing question that
has been discussed over the past
a couple of days should we be
considering one trade one way on the
kids to Mars what's the best approach to
colonize the planet with it but what you
will it's not socially acceptable to
think people will sign up to do it I
think there's plenty of people signed up
for a warrior to Mars but maybe if I
could have a show on who would consider
such an option I see some not married or
perhaps enough for a couple of missions
absolutely no I think it's sort of like
is it a one-way mission and then you die
or is it watery mission and you get
resupplied that's a big difference
wait for the second option yeah exactly
but I mean I think it's a good point
because you want to bring the spaceship
back like these spaceships are expensive
okay if they're hard to pull can't just
leave them there so whether or not
people want to come back or not it's
kind of like they can jump on if they
want but you need to face your back
thank you
I mean kind of weird like it was like
huge collection of spaceships on Mars
over time really it's like where you
spin the back and record we ship in the
back so what Tesla your goal has been to
make a better car and you've done that
with an electric vehicle that people
covet that has quite a cult following
that's upgradable but you also want to
achieve and your turn of phrase is very
nice or try to achieve this Platonic
ideal of a car right to reach your
affection so what does the perfect car
look like well I'm going to do I do use
that phrase with our assuring design
team that operationally we're in pursuit
of like ideal of the perfect car and who
knows what that looks like actually that
it I
you want to try to make every element of
the car as as flawless as possible and
they'll always be you know some degree
of imperfection but try to minimize that
and create a car that is just a landfill
in every way and I think if you do that
then the rest kind of takes care of
itself
so being innovative can be very exciting
life the doing business sometimes
requires you know assistance and
sometimes could be very boring do you
have the same fun from innovation as
from business running a business well
going to rob that you do just an
innovator engineer instead of a business
owner or runner I mean I'd love to just
do innovation work and just your
engineering but you raise a good point
because in a lot of life and general any
job there's like you have to do your
chores you know there's no nobody else
can do that for you
well it's yet I think to be successful
at almost anything you can't you have to
do the tough stuff and as well as the
enjoyable stuff you have to do the
boring stuff as well as the non boring
stuff and if you don't do your chores
then bad things will happen but if they
don't do the things that they don't like
to do then the company will be in
trouble
yeah
you're basically like it's more fun to
cook the meals they do to clean the
dishes okay but you need to clean dishes
we need to get that yes he's your boss
exactly 2001 with just distorted friend
of mine and if you asked me what I was
going to have to pay pal and if it well
you know I was wondering like I'd like
to be involved in space but I just
didn't think there's a texture as an
individual and but I was curious was to
when we wintered NASA would be standing
a team to march because I was always
gonna be the thing to do after Luke I
figured that there'd be some plan and I
just go to websites and I could read the
you know the schedule and then Martha
there oh yes like okay 2017 good okay
but actually there wasn't anything on
the website and course also like am I
can and I'll find it like what's going
on here
and it's a secret I don't know I but it
turned out that that NASA had done a
study on what it would cost attend do to
do a manned Mars mission and I this was
under Bush the first and I suppose he
asked for a 90-day study she would left
a taking office and NASA came back with
a five hundred billion dollar price tag
and he said okay maybe not billion at me
that's been five hundred billion dollars
of Juris money come in for the
government so I so then it's that good
totally shelf and it was like you were
not allowed to talk about any kind of
crude mission to Mars at NASA and anyway
so I thought well if I can do something
that word galvanize public interest that
and then that public interest would
translate to additional appropriations
from NASA increased their budget then
maybe they could do it so the foots
actually what I sort of thinking I would
do is saying that a small greenhouse for
service of Mars with seeds and
dehydrated gel and then upon landing
hydrate the general grow the plants and
the public to respond to presidents and
superlatives so this would be the
furthest that life ever traveled the
first life on Mars I try to figure out
how to do this with the proceeds that I
had from
from PayPal and I was able to figure out
how to get the cost of the spacecraft
down and the communications and the
little green house everything but the
one thing I couldn't compress was the
cost launch there's only a few options
and the us options are way too expensive
and I ended up going to Russia three
times to try to buy the biggest ICBM and
the Russian nuclear fleet that's where I
start yeah yeah go baby well yeah I mean
okay they say it was but there were some
strange trips that's for sure but it
looks like specially like you can buy
any it's a very capitalist society
somewhere so actually did negotiate a
deal to fix it by two of the ICBMs - the
nukes and but I came to conclusion after
that third trip that it wouldn't really
matter like you actually came inclusion
that my initial premise was was wrong
because I actually think those
destroyers found a will in the American
population particularly to to explore
and United States
you know maybe more than any other
country is a distillation of the human
spirit of exploration and it's really
fundamental to psyche so if people think
there's a way I think it would actually
get a lot of support but but then it
can't be just banging your head against
a wall gotta believe but this can be
done without breaking the federal budget
so that's right said okay well is there
some way to affect the cost of space
transport and an Israeli and so I got
together with a group of people over
series of Saturday's just to just try it
outside is there something super expand
'mentally super expensive about rockets
or can the cost be substantially
improved and x-head we had a bunch of
those kind of brainstorming sessions and
I can see I can see any fundamental
obstacle to improving the cost of
rockets so that's when I started SpaceX
I'll just build them myself yeah and
then but I said at that point I would
say before the probability of success
was definitely less than 30 percent I
thought it most likely not succeed but
was worth the try
IRA CEO of SpaceX and you've said that
your ultimate goal is to get humankind
to Mars
I've heard your response to the question
but these guys need to hear it why is
Mars important what is Mars matter sure
well I think it's really a fundamental
vision we need to make as a civilization
I you know what kind of future do we
want do you want a future where we are
forever confined to one planet until
some eventual extinction event however
far in the future that might occur or do
we want to become a multi-planet species
and and then ultimately be out there
among the stars being among many planets
many star systems and I think the latter
is a far more exciting and inspiring
future than the former and and Mars is
the next natural step in fact it's the
only planet we really have a shot at at
establishing a self-sustaining city on
and and I think once we do establish
such a city there will be strong forcing
function for the improvement of
spaceflight technology that will then
enable us to establish colonies
elsewhere in the solar system and
ultimately extend beyond the beyond our
solar system and and so there's a
defensive reason of protecting the
future of humanity ensuring that the
light of consciousness is not
extinguished should some calamity before
us but also that's the defensive reason
but personally I find in what it gets me
more excited is is the fact that this
would be an incredible adventure maybe
like the greatest adventure ever and it
will be exciting and inspiring and they
need to be things that excite me inspire
people yeah after you know reasons why
you get up in the morning it can't just
be solving problems it's got to be yeah
something something great thing
happening to you true yeah we talked
about this at length yesterday it's not
an exit strategy or back-up plan working
the contour
all right it's also to inspire people on
earth right and to transcend and to go
beyond our mental limits of what we
think we can achieve right I mean I
think it's sort of how incredible the
Apollo program wise and just yeah I mean
it's if you ask anyone and to name names
of humanity's greatest achievements in
20th century the Apollo program landing
on the moon would wouldn't it in many if
not most places be number one
thank you guys so much for watching the
part two series is something that we're
still experimenting with and having some
fun with - let me know what you think if
we should continue it if there's someone
else you want to see a part two version
of leave your thoughts in the comments
below and we'll see what we can do also
I'm really curious if you grew out what
did you learn most from elan in this
video what message hit home the hardest
that you're going to immediately apply
to your life for business somehow leave
in the comments and I'm going to join in
the discussion finally I want to give a
quick shout out to Kaylee and Bradley
thank you guys so much for picking up a
copy of my book your one word and taking
that picture it's awesome and I really
really really appreciate it so thank you
guys again for watching I believe in you
I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much loved I'll see you soon
we have also said in terms of where you
want to go that that developing a
high-performance sports car is not what
this is about
absolutely is yet about something else
and you want to develop a sedan yeah the
whole purpose behind Tesla the reason I
put so much of my time and money is
helping create the business is is we
want to serve as a catalyst for
accelerating the electric car revolution
the the price of gas at the pump does
not reflect the true cost of gasoline
because you have a consumption of a
public good and it's one of the most
it's what it's really a common problem a
comic you know the same thing in fishing
we're figure there's no cost to two
fishing stocks people just over fish and
you know and you have disaster led
interviews and and here we're not paying
for the cost of of the co2 concentration
in the oceans and atmospheres we're not
paying for these the ancillary effect of
the wars and all the other things at
epic at the gas pump so you effectively
have a subsidy taking place at the gas
pump because of that so the only way to
bridge that is with innovation is to try
to try to make electric cars better
sooner than they would otherwise be